how's it going bros my name is peter
pack welcome to friday repair
[Music]
yes
youtuber hits 1000 subscribers nordvpn
skillshare i've never worked with
skillshare
what the hell [ __ ] you skillshare you
ain't teaching [ __ ]
garbage norby panda however computer pop
bad skillshare
garbage thank you i remember this
this is from resident evil
55 accidentally makes an epic melody but
i harmonized it
oh
hey
[Music]
so warm
a summer day a summer wind
touching your cheeks ever so subtly
[Laughter]
dull mango that was amazing it's funny
because i remember installing that and i
was like that actually sounds pretty
nice
but you sir or man
killed it loved it huge pp
that's so cool italians the
uh italians doing italian
but you don't understand you cannot
break the pasta before you boil it
that's what they're all discussing it
was a heated debate italians
guy spends hours making literal
pewdiepie sword and does not make it
into fridays with pewdiepie
some completely random pee bruh
i mean wait okay i gotta check this egg
geggy geggy instead of video because i
can't really see it well
here we go oh it is a video nice he took
parts from
what i wake up hell yeah i like the pink
ooh oh okay hell yeah
now go kill someone add something don't
do that
do that yeah dude imagine
the kd you could have with this sword
geggy
huge peepee people in russia oh okay i
feel like i've seen this
i mean i've definitely seen the clip
where they just
keep yeah it keeps going
oh man embarrassing
russia uh
we're not so different after a
great meme don't know how it ended up on
fridays with pewdiepie but i'll
take it dude somebody talks about
martial kids when he talks about marcia
when she's
near the door i never know if she's near
the door
it's it's a scary thing remember blue
shirt kid
this is him now phil old yet hell yeah
looking like a [ __ ] chad dude
ain't nobody surprised about that let's
go blue shirt kid
can this video get same amount of likes
as dislikes
no no that's impossible
does it not say how many dislikes
exactly damn
that's hard if you had 100 million
subscribers on youtube
what's your next video how's it going
bros today we're doing another tick tock
dude i do them like once once i done
i i do them once okay
it's fun it's practically your life you
lose rebranded and you all love that
huh oh but it's tick tock and technology
screen
yeah that's the point sweden has the
first condom
hell yeah why is it small another thing
sweden invented the condoms
you're welcome everyone have a nice
blessed safe pee pee
is it true though i mean the first one
was found in sweden
yeah yeah it was found in lund lund
apparently means peepee in
a language ah they were used by
egyptians those [ __ ] rooneys
hey kids you forgot to unless the
players invited interviews to everyone
oh
all right now don't worry we have oh god
[Laughter]
[Music]
we did a live stream it was hilarious it
was a funniest stream
i've done in a while i might do a
shorter version of it because it's like
two hours and
i understand not everyone has time to
sit through that but we we builded
obstacle courses and then you had to run
through them and it was just complete
[ __ ] mayhem
uh but i forgot to unlea they kept
playing i guess
after i was done all right what do they
got what is this
i think i saw edgar's or begun whichever
will it be
because i wanted to do more of that oh
that's sick
be completely [ __ ] done because we
only just begun
yeah they did so yeah
[Applause]
oh we gotta do that let me serve your
[ __ ] lasagna
oh
[Music]
thanks to my unpaid internship
[Applause]
series
okay so the final thing we will see had
to make death run
let's go
well done guys well done i can't wait
all right i reacted to this video
[Music]
no way
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go why do i not recognize that
church where is they everyone's like
it's gothenburg i'm like
which church is that oscar the extreme
yeah
i only know this one well it's a
shuriken he must
get yeah that explains it
you live in mustaget okay i'm kidding
that's gorgeous dan anyway you're
useless
reptile you're useless
[Laughter]
[Music]
no
no i'm sorry you're not useless
like and subscribe please instead of
making fun of
lack of content let's give kids some
ideas let's go
thank you let's complaining more
constructive
yes help me
[Music]
what hey
that looks sick it's awesome bradley
back at it again
what a [ __ ] shot dude it looks so
slick
[Music]
does it actually lit up or is that
edited
same i mean if you don't want it
probably as i'm moving soon so maybe
just wait a bit i heard this
billboard was popular so i drove two
hours
three hours to see it myself let's go
the pilgrimage was worth it i can tell
i can't believe it's still up how long
do they keep ads up
i'm so confused did they just buy that
billboard
if filthy frank hit the gym more often
nah that's scared
all right the shirt hey look at reddit
comments making me crack up what about
hey oh my god he did it too that's so
cool wow
that's why they're right after each
other uh pewdiepie themed beach
dude i used to see my latest video come
on
come on uh we use this as for the
the bleeding mountain in uh antarctica
or whatever antarctic
but i couldn't find any video of it so
i'm like so i've just had this that
looks like
the same
oh another ksi a brave soul has come out
and admitted that he put on a shovel and
the
funniest thing was that i threw it
oh that's perfect that's genius i
respect that you can't do that if you
put in the shower you can't throw it at
people
hey i already have all the thumbnail
photo
faces i don't have to do them anymore
where where is this from
i got the firearm in the back a mousepad
reject modality
embrace tradition let's go it's gonna
become a thing
trust me vote pewdiepie it only makes
sense that i get into politics next
it's funny because this is true i'm like
what just happened to you
who are you when she watches the euro
finale like what are you talking what
are these words coming out of your mouth
i don't even understand
how do you say island in your language
island inside
isla
i didn't know that hey what's that
[Laughter]
why is that so funny i never thought
about it that's hilarious
sweden's superior language clearly and
the word for river says oh
oh my god this blow my mind why i never
thought about this
oh that's uh oh
they call me double of seven sir videos
miss sarah james made it with
it made it surprise food pack seven
years of watching pewdiepie let's go
it's almost cringe but very epic still
so it passed it's got a hint of irony in
it i'm sure
feels then try not to lie it's the same
thing i'm literally just getting clips
from from tick tock as the algorithm
makes it so much easier to actually fun
find much funnier uh content
i don't understand i think people are
just hooked that tick tock is
is terrible they just want a [ __ ] about
it if you guys hate it so much i'll stop
doing it like i don't care
i just think it's funny clips uh i feel
my heart crack
no how did you how did that happen
how zombie unicorn oh f's in the chat
at least
[Laughter]
not even mr beast can be bothered to
make thumbnails i love it
uh friend what's felix
it's true that's how they named me well
shell shadow is like a uh river source
right
i think i think that's what it's implied
like a river through a mound
but that's clearly wrong that's what
they actually mean there it is
yeah hindi i can't read okay hell yeah
someone did it it's like a luxury toilet
you can pee and poo
at the same time had a heart transplant
damn
it was inspiring when i pushed through
challenges through my life much love to
you in the writing community all
bless up speedy recovery wishes big
peepee blisses
felix is that you damn that looked like
my badass grandpa or something what
is it i ain't a swedish fish
god you guys are so whiny sometimes you
you really want more reddit videos i
just kind of felt like i've done
so many and like all right might space
them out a bit more i'm trying different
stuff
uh a rare footage of pewdiepie's
submissions mods are
removing rick rolls
good when you check the fridge every
five minutes for hours
and see nothing new in it see this
problem is one of those things that goes
away when you become an adult
it's one of those few exceptions of
things becoming better when you're
grown up so don't worry unless you're
poor then you're
i don't know what to tell you netflix
are you still watching someone's
daughter
well okay this might be a good good uh
test because
youtube is demonetizing me anytime i i
kiss the mic
so am i allowed to kiss g fuel we'll see
we'll see in the next video if i get the
body types for this or not we'll see
my girlfriend got a laser and she made
this for me what
how i know with a laser but that's sick
i drew pewdiepie in comic book style
mike mignola inspired
my wrapped up soon well happy birthday
mondy that looks sick
love it mike mignola i think i recognize
it
oh it's hellboy damn never realized how
cool the art for hellboy was
oh last one my girlfriend gifted the 100
milli hoodie for my 18th birthday she's
the best 19 year old
isn't that sweet happy birthdays all
around
if today's your birthday happy birthday
and stay toasty
my broskies oh subscribe as well hit the
subscribe button
yeah do it